[Music]
[Applause]
nick wright first things first co-host
of fox sports one my day is always
better when i talked to nick i saw his
tweet this morning that i am just
astounded by how many of my colleagues
love the bills this week love them in
big letters ready to anoint josh allen
ready to throw dirt on the homes the
whole thing we'll discuss plus is this
tom brady's last game will the niners
beat rogers again
wow how did your tweet sound with a
professional reading it
i got it you know you're being
self-congratulatory
and patronizing per usual but it sounded
great
i mean i'm not gonna lie
i'm like that's why he's stan patrick
and i'm me like that really i i can you
record my outgoing voicemail for me i
would i mean that really was great that
was outstanding sounded great do you
agree with me though dan a little the
the josh
how long has josh allen been better than
patrick mahomes and i i mean it's just
the hype for this guy
who 12 days ago almost lost to the jets
19 days ago literally had the worst game
of his entire career
meanwhile mahomes has never lost a home
playoff game in regulation has never
been bad in a home playoff game it seems
like a little you know a skew feels a
little bit like if in mid conference
second i'm sorry second round of the nba
playoffs last year people were like you
know what i think trey young's the best
player in the nba like
slow down a bit for me please your voice
is up uh at a pretty high level
like that's a new octave like that's a
mariah carey octave that i i'm not uh
used to hearing out of you
okay so this segment starts off with me
complimenting your voice and you just
for the first time in our relationship
taking a shot at mine yeah dan i'm a
little high strung this weekend my
friend i'm not gonna lie to you we got a
lot on the line for your you know
television viewers i'm literally wearing
chiefs red sweatpants i'm ready to go
i'm excited for this football game and
for this nonsense these bills mafia
charlatans that have been polluting my
twitter mentions for never two years to
put them down in the dirt that's what
i'm ready okay i'm with you i have the
chiefs going to the super bowl facing
the packers i'm i'm all in with you um
that was my prediction at the beginning
of the year i think the chiefs uh are
going to win this game i think we're
drunk with love with the bills with the
perfect game they played against the
patriots um so i i'm i'm with you on
that and i do think that josh allen the
highs that he gives you
we we we sometimes forget the lows that
he has as well
and and his heis rival i'm sorry to
interrupt his highs rival mahomes and
rogers yes for the highest highs of the
league in the league the difference is
his lows
rival
zach wilson's
and he hasn't gotten that out of his
game yet meanwhile
rogers and mahomes
almost never have awful games they might
have awful games by their own standards
but their level of consistency is what
separates them but here's the other
thing that just surprises me dan
that if we are just looking at this
soberly and could the bills win of
course this is not better than a buy
like the steelers game was or maybe my
most iconic phrase it's under the sports
canon now um but uh
so the bills could win josh allen could
run for a bunch of yards maybe the
chiefs can't cover staphon digs but
one team is at home
that team also has more dynamic
playmakers the better coach and the
better quarterback
the four biggest check marks are all on
that side of the ledger and i know folks
will say uh the bill's defense is better
maybe
but the bill's defense also is coming
off a stretch of 10 games
against
nine awful quarterbacks and brady and
brady beat him so i think the bill
stevens might be a touch overrated i'm
just the chiefs not being three-point
favorites at home dan
is
the most insulting thing that's happened
to the city of kansas city since bart
since you guys did your stupid barbecue
tour and that doofus was like texas
barbecue's better remember that
that carried your show for six weeks
you're welcome for that one pal
um so i'm with you on the chiefs
i i like the rams against the buccaneers
yep me too i i don't rule out the niners
doing something crazy like
you know
keeping it close enough to win the game
i just get nervous of if
if it comes down to jimmy g leading a
drive
you know debo samuel better be getting
the ball on you know 80 percent of those
carries there and the bengals against
the titans as much as i love cincinnati
my hometown team i think the titans are
better than what we're giving them
credit for being at home
all right so i don't know if there's
good or bad for the audience
we are mirrored picks across the board i
agree with everything you just said i
think that there is a part of me to go
in order
uh there is some trepidation of picking
matt stafford on the road against brady
with somebody jenna wolf said this on
our show today i i should have known
this i couldn't but it's an astounding
number tom brady is 14-2 in this round
of the playoffs that i think it might be
as impressive as seven super bowls he's
14 and two in the divisional round so
there's part of me that feels like ah
you're gonna feel dumb picking stafford
to go on the road and win
but they're so banged up and i don't
think the bucks have any way to guard
cup without doubling him and then odell
can go off we agree on the titans i i
think the bengals obviously are fun the
titans are rested they're healthier
they're well coached they've been here
before they're at home i think pick them
i really want to drill in on packers on
packers uh niners
because
they're the niners have a lot of obvious
edges
and then the one super obvious edges but
the other team has the league mvp at
quarterback and you have a guy that you
just can't trust can't even trust forget
to throw passes in the fourth quarter
can't even trust to wait for trent
williams to get set
before you do a quarterback sneak
sidebar of the sidebar
how mad is mike mccarthy at jimmy
garoppolo for fall starting there if he
just doesn't fall start we're not
killing mccarthy for the quarterback
sneak it's like buddy
i'm dying because of your mistake just
wait for trump williams to get set the
game's over none of this nonsense
happens but here's my question to you
dan
right now
obviously bray's greatest quarterback
ever i think if rogers wins the super
bowl this year
rogers versus peyton manning becomes a
really interesting conversation
if rogers loses this game at home
that feels like okay he's a tier below
yeah is that unfair is that ridiculous i
i don't think it's unfair no i think
it's because he started out great in the
postseason and then he is not he's been
average ever since then you go to one
super bowl and that was 10 years ago and
you win that while i'll say and i've
said it many times he makes the position
look as effortless as any quarterback
i've ever seen in my life maybe more so
than any other quarterback you gotta you
gotta have another one here
and i think that
having that second i mean look at eli
having two you're in the hall of fame if
stafford gets one he's in the hall of
fame probably uh roger's getting a
second if it matters to him which is
tricky
you know then he elevates himself above
brees
peyton i think he's a better quarterback
than peyton i think peyton's had more of
an impact on the game but i would put
rogers there if you want to throw in
john elway and whoever else into that
mix i understand it but if you don't get
to two
you know then you're you're down on the
list
like listen
it's unfathomable
the idea that mahomes never gets to
another super bowl but even if he
doesn't he's been to more than rogers
right yeah that's kind of crazy you know
what i mean and so i think roger's
already ahead of breeze but i also think
it should be noted rogers first five
playoff games
he's four and one and the one loss they
scored 45 points and lost in overtime
that was the cr it was his first playoff
game ever that was the one where he
actually got strip sacked in the first
play of overtime and arizona scored
since then dan he's seven and eight and
now are all those losses on him no the
nfc championship game against the
falcons for example a few years ago
falcons i think scored 28 straight to
start the game but let's go to the
seattle game for a second
everyone kills mccarthy and they should
they blew it down the stretch
with that said
rogers was one touchdown two picks and
had a 55 passer rating in that game like
they had opportunities to make it to
where uh an unblowable lead i would
argue the 15 15-1 season coming off the
super bowl losing that home playoff game
to eli and the giants that one it didn't
sting as much things you're like oh
he'll be back
but he hasn't been back you can and now
you're at home again you're the
healthier team you're the more rested
team i think they i don't know they have
to win the super bowl but they have to
win this game and i don't know if they
will who presents the biggest roadblock
for green bay in your opinion
well i think
this team i think the niners
more than the rams or the buccaneers
oh yeah i think the bucks are too beat
up i think the bucks are too beat up
they have played too many games
the rams
are an interesting one however
there is a part of me that says
matt stafford going into green bay
if there's a mental part of sports at
all that place has been house of horrors
for him his whole career and then he's
on the precipice of the super bowl and
that's like to me that yeah i think the
cold weather hurts them i think this is
the game the niner or the bucks sorry
the packers did not want was this team
with this running game and this coach
coming into their building he's nick
wright you can see him on first things
first monday through friday on fox
sports one
uh
haven't talked to you since uh the
lakers fallout
how does this end
oh i don't know dan
you know probably with lebron winning
the scoring title that's what i'll focus
on guy you know you're 19 and scoring
title seems pretty good guys no score uh
it's not great dan here's what i find
interesting
a lot of people deserve a lot of blame
here uh rob palinka deserves blame
everyone's like oh but lebron made them
make the trade lebron couldn't even get
them to hire tyler so lebron has some
juice but he's not literally calling in
the trades pulling to deserve some blame
uh obviously vogel deserves some blame
rust deserves some blame there's a lot
of blame to go around it'd be nice if
anthony davis were healthy
but it is astounding to me
how many people
are caping for frank vogel this week oh
my god this is so unfair it is
it's unfair
wait is it oh you can't treat a champion
coach you can't you're like dude i was
just like for the people saying it's
ridiculous for vocal to be on the hot
seat can you tell me your favorite frank
vogel coaching moment what's your
favorite frank vogel adjustment did you
love that it took him a dozen games to
figure out that russ and rondo can't be
on the court at the same time did you
love when nine months after the
brilliant tactician steve nash realized
deandre jordan is cooked he was still
starting games for your team like i do
not put this all on vogel
but there have been better coaches fired
for far less malfeasance and i i find it
very peculiar it's an odd venn diagram
of people in the media who have been the
loudest and most most articulate lebron
james critics and people in the media
who are all of a sudden giant frank
vogel fans they're like oh my god do you
remember him with hibbert look at those
defensive roads shut up
stop it uh i just thought that if you're
gonna fire him fire him that's all you
leak somebody leaked that information to
the athletic and now
you know everybody's waiting and then i
just wondered if he was getting on the
plane to go on the road trip and then
found out that he was but it just feels
like
you know it's inevitable that's going to
happen that's the only part of this
that's not fair if if he's your guy then
let him coach if not then firing
i agree with that with that said they
just played the pacers his previous team
and now tonight they're in orlando maybe
they're like hey i got friends there
maybe some family a reunion tour yeah
let him take the trip that is nice yeah
i think that is nice there is an odd the
line in that game by the way
is the lakers minus just five
and like assume lebron's gonna play
that tells me there are people in vegas
that think
that
the lakers players might be trying to
get him fired because as bad as the
lakers have been orlando is a travesty
of a team and for the lakers only be
five point favorites i think there's
some concern from the bookmakers that
the lakers might try to expedite this
firing process
does frank vogel
accompany the team
back to los angeles from this road trip
i'm gonna say yes okay i'm gonna say yes
i think he does i think frank vogel
survives i think he does just enough to
survive until anthony davis comes back
and then there's you know a little
resurgence again i don't know if i said
this earlier but lebron james is going
to win the scoring title he's in year 19
dan yeah uh that's got to count for
something lead the league in 30 point
games you know is he not a scorer though
of course uh and so no no he's a scorer
he's just not a shooter
that's right dan higher career you know
uh three-point percentage than kobe and
michael but that's fine huh that's right
not a shooter
but i'm on your side with lebron
oh i know dan but i don't it's not just
you and i talking there's people
listening i'm talking to them
uh but i but i'm on your side you
sometimes go over the side
there's nothing to go overboard you're
saying i go overboard do you think there
were i don't know if there were physics
there's that voice going up again
there's that octave i don't
i don't know
if there were physics talk shows
in the 19 ops
but do you think people were like listen
i lie i'm an einstein guy too but you go
a little too far like no you can't go
too far
well yeah you can you can't you can
yeah yeah you can you can go
that is bullying
you're bullied i'm i'm bullying you well
i'm sorry that i didn't i didn't know
that i i didn't mean you you know what
you know what this is called this is
punching down
you're a broadcast hall of famer with
millions of dollars and millions of
listeners and viewers i'm just an up and
coming this is how i got here
yeah by by bullying
did you know by punching down by
punching down true story dan and then
you can you can hang up on me okay all
right uh
i'm a
senior in high school going on a tour of
syracuse university
and happened to you know set up a
meeting with the dean of newhouse
he'll remain nameless dean ruben i'll
never forget it um but uh and he's talks
with me and my mother
says well you know i've seen your record
i've seen this you know i'd be shocked
if you're not admitted
love to have you but i just you want to
do radio right i'm like yeah that's all
i've ever want to do is radio
he's like well i'm sorry to tell you
it'll never work your voice is awful for
radio he's like oh thanks dean take that
dean but now dan patrick's co-signing it
so maybe he was right all along yeah he
was yeah yeah oh he was
you're such
i'm sorry i
i like sometimes i don't know i'm
speaking
you ever thought maybe i'm a little
self-conscious about this you ever
thought maybe i'm like ah maybe the
reason that even to this day i smoke one
dollar black and wild cigars by the pack
is because i'm like one day i'll get the
grizzled broadcaster voice i am
literally killing myself so i can sound
like you i complimented you in the
beginning and now you're all making me
uh mclovin not not your old mclovin i'm
talking about from the actual movie the
original mclovin with the voice it's not
fair it's not fair and it's me i want an
apology before i come on again i would
say brown liquor
i did that too oh
yeah more of it
more of it
look at him look at this guy he'll never
be as good as me as not as always
what a jerk uh i'll apologize the next
time before you come on
fritz lose my number yeah
wow
but in the meantime i just want to say
good luck to patrick
[Laughter]
uh do you want to hear fritzy's patrick
mahomes impersonation
i don't want to hear from anyone
involved with the show ever okay all
right fair enough all right
thank you nick good-bye all right that's
nick wright he does a great job at fox
sports one he does
all right we'll all right we'll take a
break we're back after this